and now joining us from down under
please welcome
adam long take it away
hello from australia and yes with a last
name like long it was nominated
determinism that i would be here with
the long now foundation
have you ever wondered why it is when
somebody sneezes everybody immediately
says bless you even if they're not
religious even if they don't know the
person even if they're somewhere
inappropriate like a cinema and the
reason that happens is because of a
story that was told hundreds of years
ago that a sneeze was the soul escaping
and bless you pushes it back in
stories influence our behavior they
change the way we think and the way we
interact with the world
but in the modern world stories are
being told mainly by this group
marketers just ask naomi klein because
marketers are putting so much effort
into repeating stories over and over
again they're infiltrating our psyche
our culture and our very infrastructure
so today i want to take you through
three examples of how marketers have
really ruined along now that's right
they've taken some stories and done some
real damage with how those stories have
spread
we'll start by going back to the 1920s
here's a typical street scene in the
1920s for new york the street was a
place for people to
live play commerce socialize and then
came the car suddenly the streets
started to get dangerous and as
pedestrian deaths mounted
public outcry grew
a couple of states got together and said
let's put some speed limiters on this
confounding contraption so they can't go
faster than 15 miles an hour
now the motor industry didn't like the
sounds of that they wanted to drive fast
so they came up with a solution these
guys
now in australia would call them a bogan
some call them hex some call them yokels
but at the time they called them jays
jays was someone who came from the
countryside and didn't know how to act
in the city
they became the first jaywalkers
and the idea of jaywalking is that
instead of people dying because of
reckless drivers people are dying
because of reckless pedestrians
that term that story has changed the
very fabric of our cities not just
blaming the pedestrians for their deaths
but also deciding where people can and
can't walk who's at fault when something
happens
can you imagine if the story was
different and we talked about jay
drivers instead of jaywalkers what might
our cities look like with a different
story
now around the same time in the 20s
tobacco companies noticed that there
weren't as many women as men who were
smoking only 3 percent of women were
smokers while nearly 60 percent of men
were so they hired a pr firm led by
someone called edward bernays who
happened to be the nephew of sigmund
freud
like all good marketers he looked for
influences who will the market look up
to now at the time suffragettes were in
full swing in first wave feminism these
were the people that women were looking
up to so we teamed up with them and at
the easter parade of 1927 he got women
to light cigarettes and call them
tortures of freedom
turning the act of lighting and smoking
a cigarette from a dirty habit into
something underpinning feminism
now if that's not a compelling story i
don't know what is who wouldn't want to
support feminism
but the damage was done you can see that
by the time this started came through
eight times as many women were smoking
as there were in 1927 when that first
story around cigarettes being tortured
for freedom first infiltrated our
culture
now do you want to accept this cookie
probably you do i expect you accept many
every single day and this is another
example where perhaps just using a
different term a different story for
cookies we'd end up somewhere different
now the term cookies was invented by lou
montelli based on fortune cookies where
some code was trapped inside some other
code and hidden
but what it means is that these cookies
infiltrate and extract our data they
follow us around the internet and if you
think we're protected by privacy
policies well on the left there you can
see the pink one is instagrams i'm sure
we all read and agreed to that one and
on the right you can see just how much
data when printed facebook collects on a
single individual
so the question i have for you is what
would our state of privacy look like if
instead of calling them cookies we
called them something else maybe creepy
tracking code that watches you just like
someone watching you walk around a mall
perhaps our attitudes to privacy would
be very very
different but there is hope because
knowing that stories can do damage means
we can also elevate the stories that do
help and there have been plenty of
examples of those throughout history as
well there's the wave of uh minimalism
which has really been championed by the
likes of patagonia saying don't buy this
jacket or think of all the stories that
were told to make germ theory a reality
and get people to start doing things as
simple as washing their hands or think
about the movement of social enterprises
that are turning what people wear into a
statement for what they believe in
like consciousness my own company so
there is hope as long as we're mindful
and choiceful about the stories we tell
we can shape the long now for the better
don't let the marketers do more damage
thanks adam
uh
i'm wondering do you see any examples of
a
potential marketing
ruin
happening right now one that we won't
see the effects of for a long time
oh
yeah they're coming in in all the time
aren't they uh there's a question around
will the metaverse be an equivalent to
the world we live in outside for example
uh there are stories around whether our
our destiny uh lies in space or whether
our destiny is solving the the problems
here so that that's an interesting one
the fault the false dichotomy saying do
we go to space or do we fix the problems
here on earth
marketers need to solve that one and get
people thinking long term
and not get distracted by the short-term
thinking
all right
well thanks for joining us adam
thank you very much glad to be here